التعلم في الصغر كالنقش على الحجر والتعلم
في الكبر كالنقشي على الماء هكذا تربينا
لكنها مقولات ربما تبعث على الكسل ولعل
اهم سؤال يمكن ان يساله الانسان مهما بلغ
عمره ماذا تعلمت اليوم
[موسيقى]
ولكن هل البالغون يستطيعون التعلم في اي
عمر الاجابه نعم والعلم يؤيد ذلك الدماغ
البشري قادر على استقبال المعلومات
الجديده ما دام الانسان يتنفس وبالنسبه
لكبار السن ما يمنعهم عن مواصله التعلم هو
اعتقادهم على الاغلب بانهم غير قادرين على
التعلم
[موسيقى]
حالي يصبح التعلم اليومي فرضا لخيارا
تخيلوا كل تلك التغييرات في عالم العمل كل
تلك الروبوتات القادمه كل تلك المنافسه مع
الذكاء الاصطناعي اذا كنت في الثلاثين او
الاربعين او الخمسين هل تستسلم لكونك قد
تصبح غير نافع
[موسيقى]
شركات عديده تؤمن بتدريب الموظفين داخليا
بشكل دوري مصطلحات مثلو ابن الشركه ونجاحك
من نجاح المؤسسه لا تستقيموا بدون تعليم
في العمل وتعليم من دونها نهايه
ولعلنان استذكر قول غاندي عش حياتك كانك
ستموت غدا وتعلم كانك ستعيش للابد لصباح
العربيه هند ابراهيم
[موسيقى]